hello Apple the devil are you today we
are played battle royale like clitty
almost every day of my life but this
time we are going to try some sort of
challenge but I was hoping that you guys
would send in challenges in the comments
below and we try to do one of them each
week it doesn't have to be in fortnight
it can be in any games or mondays are
going to be where we play video games
just for the fun of it
but we need a challenge as well it can't
just be straight-up gameplay we have to
do something different to stand up from
the millions upon millions of other
youtubers and twitch streamers so we're
going to do the minimal challenge so
basically you can only build a one by
one tower that's one tile high that's it
there's no other way and if someone
builds over the top of you you have to
give them the high ground and try and
win from the low ground oh let's go to
El Pueblo have you been to El Pueblo
lately it's bloody fantastic it's my
favorite place in the entire game but
just to finish off so I can build the
one by one but only one tile high but I
want to retain if there's a freaking
mountain in front of me I'm allowed to
climb up that beast okay so I'm not
stuck at the foot of it and losing
without having a chance so minimal
builds one by ones one tile high right
let's do this let's go to my favorite
landing spot in the entire game this is
El Pueblo
before the end of the day we will win a
game only building one tile hi and we
have a blue shiny to start with let's
start the action from the back section
hello let's go around instead I reckon
your weight as my dude I appreciate that
ok the problem now we literally have no
builds and there's another person there
do we go aggressive do we backtrack what
would you do in this scenario well I
would run run for my life it's pretty
good for low in here reloaded [ __ ] oh
here we go hello ELISA the companion
before white which means he's one hit
from death come on come talk to us yes
indeedy-do thank you
so yeah there's a few people that come
here but usually it's not like tilting
towers where there's 50,000 people in
the second you kill someone someone's on
your back to kill you here it's more
spread out all those even less people so
I think and about four people London
here I don't know if the fourth one died
so we need to keep our wits about us but
we'll just start looting basically enjoy
it
thing isn't a grenade launcher we're
gonna win this game we are gonna win
this game oh look at this hunting rifle
and shields ice leopard this bad boy so
I think he's just east I'm very certain
he's just east that we shall find out
yeah he's there he's at what see what
you know he's running over here he looks
to the wrong direction did you see him
and then we just jump back out so he
looks the wrong direction that's didn't
factor do a replay
note to self Adam do a replay here
showing the other person's point of view
if they see you and they don't take
their shot run behind an object and
they'll keep following your eye line or
their eye line toward the way they think
you're going and then you can come back
round the corner and pop them in the
head simple as peace easy peasy
what did you have young man drum - drum
drum gun I like it when the meat goes
baby make your booty go oh that drum -
drum drum gun I promised myself I
wouldn't sing because I'm sure I'm
losing subscribers by the second it's
worth it it's worth it alright gonna
collect some mats we're gonna go up the
hill and use the rift and we're going to
try and dive bomb someone I think that's
the best way to approach this situation
no there's one so I usually go straight
towards paradise parents because usually
about this time someone has won the
battle there and they've collected
everything from every building so then
we just take it from them two chests and
to race how have I been playing for so
long I've missed these ridiculous come
on give me some good chug chug
mighty gods chug chug
yeah I didn't know about that I might
add that to my my typical run now anyway
who has worked at Paradise Palms hello
anybody here my name is Adam from El
Pueblo they've come to take over your
elbow bleeped oh I've no idea if that
Spanish was correct in the slightest but
he sounded like I knew what I was on
about didn't it we got more slurp so we
got slips for days it must be so he's
there can you see him he's playing
basketball going lastic oh you got this
Oh guilty as hell but he got his shot
off he got the shot off he should be a
happy guy loot for days look for days so
there's only 27 people left so we're
probably gonna get 10 kills at best 26
people left we'll have to really run if
you want to get more kills if we wanted
bucket loads of kills it's still the
best place to go is tilted towers
whereas el pueblo he's only good for
about 2 2 or 3 4 kills sometimes though
there's been my 20 people there and it's
been so confusing but I really recommend
el pueblo and you have to say like that
that's the rule you can't say normally
it has to be said el pueblo alright
let's do some dive bomb in there lad
tract anybody a little raw is there
another rift down here the we can
piggyback on yes there is but usually I
find someone looking at oh you've seen
it have you seen it what's wrong is next
corner it's gonna win us the game magic
balloon upon hi give us a check joke
launch but that'll do darling thank you
very much and I hate those types of
weapons so we should get going instead
okay there's a bit of a track now so
what could we do lots of people like to
know about setting so we'll talk about
those for a second and I would love to
play on 10:10 sensitivity on a
controller that is but the problem is if
I do that I become terrible at all of
the game so if I just played battle
royale I would do that most definitely
but to be good at other games as well I
try to keep my settings around eight in
seven here yeah yeah X 8 and y 7 so the
no axis left the right axis is 2.8 and
the up down the yes axis the reason why
I do that is because we lock down axis
the y axis is slightly improved it
slightly increased anyway it's naturally
that way because of the way your thumb
works and the muscles in your thumb so
the up-down motion is always slightly
quicker than the left/right motion so
that's why I always offset those and
look we have a knob we have a know but
never know what to do with these is
going to kill me so the rule is I can
only break this is not going well I like
your scar though mister right here's my
warn hi there we go okay I can go above
that fair enough this is very strange
it's really weird not being able to
battle but luckily he doesn't know how
to build battle I'm going to get killed
by this guy on time well I'm going to
use my one tile Hyrule
if you only knew I wasn't allowed to
build more than one tile hi but thank
you for the medkit I will definitely
take it yeah most of my issues come with
people who have no skins because I just
don't know how to approach them because
sometimes their gods and sometimes they
like that guy and they're just confused
the hell out of me so yeah I get killed
by those all the damn time we're good we
are good
shall we do next I know it's not as
great in season 5 as it used to be but I
do enjoy it
but I thought let's look around yeah
what we're talking about we're talking
about sensitivity weren't we yes
sensitivity so yeah my starting point is
87 for all games around that area anyway
because you can transfer those skills
into other games whereas if you're just
sticking with battle royale just go for
it and go for Tenten and get practicing
so you can flick shot like the best of
them
I can't I simply cannot do it I don't
have the dedication to learn because
then I would be covertly unlearning in
other games if that makes any sense at
all hmm I feel like I'm making
educational commentary I'm the wrong
kind of YouTube that's what happens
let's go to say we can only build one hi
this has not been that challenging so
far I'm going to regret saying that I'm
gonna take a sniper to the head or
something well what we'll do is anything
in here there's nothing in here I'll be
on the bottom floor so let's go for it
come on we still want to choke joke we
still want it
no Jack Jack Jack Jack yeah now let's
pop this and take the chicken's room you
little bastard
I want my chug-chug-chug what would you
do here anyway I'm just going up
technically I'm still one tile high
because this is a structure that's
already here so I'll just reinforce
myself
right if he's over the top of me I am
buggered oh boy it's a bomber come back
me lady do you want to fight or not
no come on then are you going where you
going girlfriend what are you going
girlfriend I beat you there we will meet
again maybe not today but maybe in the
next circle I shall take your life bride
bummer mm-hmm right well beat her in and
then we'll try and take her out when
she's not looking because I'm scum
and that's what's gummy people do when
they can only build one tile hi does
anybody else get extremely stressed when
their health is on 99 I can't handle it
the OCD is killing me 99
bloody hell well 99 shield it's really
hurting my mind right where are you love
where it was a bright bomber the other
one wasn't it and you over here no she's
gonna get me and I'm not going to know
where she is
that's a nice erection off lovely
erection there people aren't used to
erection jokes that's what you get here
high-class car battery from low quality
skill right you stop oh you're so nice
to me you take this Napa to deface and I
get the easy skull trooper leader kill
but that was not the goal Bill Trotter
belt battered so we can't get involved
in the build battle but we will go up
there just checks nobody on the right
and then we'll come back round I'm just
getting that bright bomber she was
somewhere round here
oh well here we go so there's two of
them and go on you luck or have a scrap
pressure you
this is why I'm terrible with a funding
right
can't knock it down IVA gone who's gonna
win that battle so if I could build I
would be attacking more but it's a bit
worrying not being able to build more
than one tile high when you get there so
we'll use my other tactic just get some
height go higher don't go don't build
please don't build I still got mine one
there's my one one okay I won't go any
higher I won't go any higher come round
come and see me yeah oh they stole my
kill just stole my girl your son of a
[ __ ] I will go and hide whilst I'm
waiting there's still of another person
that was and that was an additional
person so there's four people that one
person died so there's still two up
there scrapping do we want the kills we
want the win it's a tough choice it's a
tough choice and I can't build what am i
doing I'm not allowed to build is there
a way up can we get all the way up here
no we can't
oh I've launched bad of course let's get
involved
- I know too damn high say hello to my
little friend
El Pueblo the village of death No yeah
we hit one didn't get a kill people
start stick people you gotta stop
stealing my kills man right let's go
finish off the last one there he's
called Opus [ __ ] you up
what a lovely name you have there mr.
rabbit don't know why I'm talking so
kentley I really don't have a clue why
I'm speaking so camp apologies I'm
getting a bit into this it's great let's
move in so in terms of a challenge it's
not really leave a challenge yeah how's
it no one has build battle does to a
level where we are so insignificant for
them that they can smash it in no time
instead we're having an easy run famous
last words
you know in the last five everyone will
build like a crazy man
alright I'm allowed to build up to
higher places online that's that's
completely fine I don't have to be on
the low ground all the time just when
I'm here I can only use a one by one
but who needs it no and you can be a
cabbage bush god
what's behind me then I hate the way
brick builds in alright we're not
cracking but we're all right we got a
hundred health we got grenades galore
and as long as we don't make that bloody
bright bomber we're fine yeah that
bright bomber did worry me I'm gonna
give him a name check when we annihilate
him if we ever see him again no for a
second marathon Sauron he definitely
came in from this angle also he is our
nemesis for the day
oh ah speak of the devil
right I'm using a little bit of height
there's my one tile I definitely don't
you dare build battle me don't have the
materials to fight
what are you doing bro what are you I'm
not gonna let you do that you is going
down and how come I've become a ghetto
man off with certain voices the voices
in my head telling me the poets should
be doing this in a lot u-dor wrestling
accent there's all the path not taken
okay where we go where we go we got we
got gear for days bro oh guy ring up
this is why I'm scared
I've never called the shop unnaturally
hit it it's all looking Oh somebody's
built up here right well creep round
we'll get up there with them and then
we'll try and stalk them we'll get as
close as we can here we go here we go yo
here we go yo so what's the what what's
the scenario areas didn't and didn't do
is gone well you gon know you were my
girl
oh okay this is not going well I'm using
my one-by-one skill
this can be my one by one this tiny
little block of nothingness
oh you're farming so your lawn mats good
to know
you poked your head please bow get your
bloody well no he's going for my noob
don't keep it makes my noob no it was my
Kel leave him alone no not a bills
battles not to build pacify curly go
please don't build battle me please
don't build but I've gotta get down all
right well if we've got to come down
he's got to come down we want this at
floor level please don't be a table
Bilbo come on battle is on the ground
we're ready come on
and he's off again oh he's one of those
he's still battling himself you're lucky
that I'm not allowed to build battle
I'll wait for you down here do you think
he's still build battling himself now
I bet he is about this is like eight
tiles high by the time he realizes he's
on his own Oh still five left
don't know where the new base I really
want to kill the noob unless I am the
noob new obsession I can hear him hang
on I got lucky I i invisible i I nice
build battling with you let's go see how
high he actually built this is hilarious
oh my word how high did he go why why
how well if he floats your boat dude
that's all good
three two one left is about to treat you
easy over there you win the bush day in
the bush
he's not in the sky where could it be
where are you oh no I'm hi apologies I
forgot I completely forgot that I wasn't
allowed to be hi
let's go down we're gonna one by one and
luckily it looks like it's some low
level come on shoot me Dave where are
you okay build battle he's on please
don't go too high please oh no no okay I
have no idea how to win this one we're
just gonna have to wash I t's already
behind us where is he what we could do
no just editing this is not going well
wouldn't hit from death right we need to
bring him down and we knew you pinged
him a couple of times that's not bad
that's not bad can't build battle can't
build battle get back down oh the storm
nah there's no like this what did not
deserve that in the slightest oh my
frickin word that storm absolutely saved
us Wow
so lucky so look anyway that's el pueblo
what do you think of that for a starting
point I quite like it it's one of the
nicest places to go you don't have to
bite to many people and you come out
with I believe gills good night okay
that's pretty terrible but but we didn't
build above one tile high and fight I
broke the rule of you times because I'm
still learning but I enjoyed that what
do you think shall we keep going with
these challenges each week if you've got
one for me send it my way any video game
at all and when I say it only video game
I mean it cuz in a couple of weeks we're
gonna play spider-man on the ps4 if you
fancy going through the story with me
that'd be pretty cool anyway I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade this is our new
spot on a Monday bit of Monday Madness
so it needs a name help me out what name
can we give this new feature where we
just play video games for the sake of
playing video game
anyway I'll shut up it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time lots of love from
El Pueblo